it depends whether you like the computer
science the economics
or the history but my recommendations
would be
you know obviously the bitcoin white
paper that's uh and satoshi's
complimentary writings that's very
important is to try and understand the
intentions behind the system
and also to understand the system
without having your
view colored by some third parties
description of it
most descriptions of bitcoin are really
bad uh so the
just go to the originals go to the hal
finis post
satoshi's post on bitcoin talk there's a
huge amount of lucidity there
and actually most of our questions about
bitcoin today that we have a decade
later were really answered in those
earliest days
people just don't know it the canonical
economic work relating to bitcoin
a lot of people don't like it i think
it's fine would be
the bitcoin standard a lot of people
don't like it i just read it it's good
yeah i like it i think it's it's a good
uh description of sort of the austrian
perspective
and then how it relates to bitcoin there
isn't that much about bitcoin in there
but i think the point is once you've
understood you know safedean's view
of monetary policy bitcoin makes a ton
of sense so you don't actually need to
argue for it that much
so the bitcoin standard is a good
introduction to sort of the orthodox
thought
in bitcoin um there's a more recent
book called layered money which i liked
um by nick batia
which goes into more depth about what i
was talking about early in the
conversation the layered approach
to scaling and that's a really critical
thing to understand
then technical books about bitcoin i
like grocking bitcoin
uh which is a very computer
science-heavy one
there's a good textbook um called uh
bitcoin and cryptocurrency
technologies by
arvind naranian i think he's um
a princeton computer science professor
which is really good at building
intuition
antonopoulos's books uh mastering
bitcoin are good
then there's like simpler intuition
building books that aren't hardcore on
the economics or the protocol design
so you have like inventing bitcoin by
john pritzker which is good you have
bitcoin clarity by qr bickers
as you can tell i have like a my
bookshelf is like mostly bitcoin books
okay well that's a good selection and of
course like you said your
your writing and your book that comes
out
this year or next year next year i think
i'm gonna need 18 months
okay uh but you know there most of the
good bitcoin content is just
online on medium on twitter so
um it's it's a decentralized you know
consensus kind of thing
you